si le parti de Marine Le Pen fait mine
aujourd'hui de s'occuper de
l'endométriose c'est pour mieux
camoufler son projet fondamentalement
opposé aux droits des
[Musique]
femmes l'article 1 vise à créer une
affection de longue durée exonérante
spécifique aux femmes atteintes
d'endométriose afin de prendre
précisément en compte les spécificités
de cette maladie et de faire face à des
dispositifs de prise en charge
institutionnel trop restrictifs à savoir
la L30 et 31 concrètement si vous
adopter cette proposition de loi les
frais de santé liés à l'endométriose
seront pris en charge à 100 % dans la
limite du plafond de remboursement de
l'Assurance Maladie cette exonération du
ticket modérateur concernerait les
consultations examens et soins
médicaments ainsi que
l'hospitalisation les frais de santé en
rapport avec l'endométriose n'auraient
pas à être avancé toutes les femmes
atteintes d'endométriose bénéf tiront du
tiers payant le rassemblement national
serait devenu comme par enchantement le
défenseur de la cause des femmes mais si
tel était le cas si vous aviez écouté ce
que disent et défendent les associations
de patientes sur ce sujet de
l'endométriose vous n'auriez pas osé
nous présenter une telle proposition loi
les derniers convertis compensent
toujours la fraîcheur de leur conviction
par la fermeté de leur expression mais
cela ne dupe personne n'êtes-vous pas le
le parti qui avait refusé d'allonger à
14 semaines le délai pour avorter en
France n'êtes-vous pas le parti qui
avait refusé d'inscrire ce droit
élémentaire à l'avortement qui refusait
d'inscrire ce droit élémentaire à
l'avortement dans votre constitution
nêtes-vous pas le parti dont les
eurodéputés se sont abstenus dans la
résolution visant à condamner fermement
l'interdiction quasi totale de
l'avortement en Pologne ces gens ont la
stratégie des coucou ils prennent nos
combats ils prennent nos luttes ils
prennent nos mots ils prennent nos
auteurs ils prennent nos autrices avec
Simone de beauoir réveillez
le groupe écologiste s'opposera à cette
loi et s'opposera toujours aux
tentatives de récupération de l'utérus
des femmes pour autre chose que notre
liberté à disposer de notre corps nos
corps nos choix nos corps nos luttes ce
texte qui pouvait susciter un un espoir
pour les femmes atteintes d'endométriose
est désormais vide je le retire donc je
suis euh député mais je suis surtout
dépité
merci